we're here with three-time US Champion
Grandmaster gata Kamsky this tournament
gada has become a lot different in the
sense that you went two decades without
winning one now you've won two in a row
nobody's won three in a row I believe
since Walter brown in the 70s is it just
getting more and more difficult to
defend your title well okay but last
year a card in place so frankly it
wasn't quite as strong as this year for
example so this year will be a really
strong tournament and it's round-robin
we shouldn't everybody plays each other
and it's great I'm just looking forward
to you know to meeting all the strongest
players in the US and and soon we're
gonna have the Olympia so it's important
you know to realize who is playing well
and you know it's fun I'll say that
everybody is quite dangerous
of course he carves you got a favorite
defending my title is it's not the
primary objective my primary objective
is to play well chess and have fun yeah
I think just like an every other sport
if you get older it gets hard to compete
with the younger players that's the
primary aspect to me like life is more
than chess chess you know because if you
continue playing in church just until 14
it means you're a really strong person
to devote your whole life to chest I'm
just
quite ready to do that last year when
you left the US Championship you said
that some of the effective you had some
surprises or you were feeling very
confident in your match with TOEFL
Lawson in fact you went on to beat him
does winning the championship give you a
lot of confidence I came to the match
was really angry and it had to do with a
lot of history between me and what
happened I was too powerful it went back
many years so I was really pissed off
and I just wanted to show that you know
that that match that I lost to him
before it was really close it wasn't
shown on the score but it was really
close and it would have went both ways
so do you play better chess when you're
sort of mad at the opponent oh that's
very unusual for me because usually you
know I go to play chess it's like it so
we both creating something it's like my
opponent is not really my opponent but
there's somebody who is helping create a
chess masterpiece but in that match it
was a clash of personalities because
chess is also a sport well good luck
trying to win your third consecutive
u.s. championship I'm just looking to
have fun tournament and we shall
dispense fair play look for some good
games thank you